nearly all the Democratic presidential
contenders could have something to say
about the shootings when they visit the
Iowa State Fair this weekend a new poll
shows former Vice President Joe Biden
leading the Democratic field in Iowa
yesterday he repeated his claim that
President Trump encourages white
supremacists at O'Keefe is at the Iowa
State Fairgrounds in Des Moines ed Biden
is standing by those statements that's
right Anthony he is he said it's
something that has to be said and here
at the fair he found some people who
agree but unlike other Democratic
candidates who now say they believe the
president is a white supremacist Biden
says he won't go that far former Vice
President Joe Biden is not backing down
from his comments linking President
Trump to the growth of white supremacy
his message resonated with at least some
people here at the Iowa State Fair a new
poll shows Biden maintaining his
comfortable lead in Iowa senator
Elizabeth Warren is now in second up 12
percent from where she stood with voters
four months ago is also campaigning in
Iowa and was one of the first Democratic
candidates to say the president is a
white supremacist he can't keep trying
to stir this up give aid and comfort
being embraced by the white supremacists
and then say oh but not me no he's
responsible
then there's California senator Kamala
Harris who's hoping to boost ur numbers
here by launching a statewide RV tour
and becoming the first major candidate
to release a TV ad in Iowa that's what
I'm fighting for
but many voters we spoke to at the fair
remain undecided I think it just right
where I say you know I'm gonna I'm
definitely gonna vote for that guy now
in addition to attending the state fair
to maybe try a fried Twinkie or a pork
chop on a stick
several of the candidates will speak at
a Democratic Party dinner about two
hours north of here tonight and at least
14 of them will be attending a hastily
arranged forum on gun violence here in
Des Moines tomorrow just a week after
those mass shootings in Texas and Ohio
Anthony and I'd stay away from the fried
Twinkies if I were you but thank you